as tropical storm Ian slowly turns
across Florida sometimes it speeds less
than 10 miles an hour the danger zone is
continually shifting to the North and
the East eventually though this system
is also expected to hit Georgia and the
Carolinas Chris Van Cleave is on the
road for us today he's following the
damage he's also keeping track of what
this all means for travelers on the road
Chris good to see you this morning what
are you seeing
Gail we left Tampa this morning we know
that there are about 300 000 people in
the Tampa area without power reports of
power lines down trees in the road we're
on Interstate 75 traffic is light we can
show you that picture now traffic is
light which is exactly what First
Responders want they want people to stay
sheltered in place stay at home stay off
the road so the power Crews can get out
so the emergency crews can get out now
for people traveling airports on the
Gulf Coast largely going to be out of
commission today we know that uh the the
airports in on the other side of the
coast in Miami and Fort Lauderdale are
assessing flights likely to resume there
we expect Key West to reopen but in in
places like Tampa Saint Pete Sarasota
assessments are being made unlikely that
there will be much flight activity for
people trying to get back here today
that may restart by Friday a lot of
airlines are offering refunds
cancellations flexibility to rebook the
other thing that's going on here Disney
World has closed in the Orlando area a
lot of hotels are closed so that's
creating some chaos for people who maybe
were trying to plan a vacation Disney
has asked people not to try to check
into hotels uh in the Orlando area until
at least tomorrow and if you're thinking
about a vacation right now it's still a
very treacherous situation for a lot of
Florida Airbnb and vacation rentals
those refunds are being left up to the
hosts if we can come back out here live
here's a look at 75 we're about 100
miles from downtown Fort Myers I know it
gets worse from here we're still feeling
pretty strong wind gusts 30 40 miles an
hour that's going to continue as we go
south and uh what we've we've seen trees
down uh we've seen we saw some some
minor damage in this area we know
hundreds of thousands of people are in
the dark here
gonna be even more so as we
we Monitor and bringing updates so the
wins
uh Chris Van Cleef we're starting to
lose your shot and your audio there and
heart headed part of the country as
you're on the road for us uh Chris thank
you very much uh we've got the majority
of his message yeah we got the we got
the message there the winds really start
to kick in yeah they go sideways I'm
surprised they have power even there
yeah even though further north